you know what i'm thinking the first one
is um korean porridge
smart
wood do you give me the three bears
version in korean not the language but
culturally
the porridge is too hot it's too cold
it's just right
oh don't go
yeah all right so oh those are pigs the
other ones are bears maybe in korea what
would they be okay let me just do the
there's old fairy tales oh it's almost
brand new to hear it again if you want
to hear it right
long time ago in the 17th century can i
do it in the accent because it's better
sure
long time no i'll do american if you're
going to say the 17th century you don't
need to say it a long time ago
like just
but in the in the fairy tale that's what
it says in the books
a long long time ago in a galaxy far far
away that's something that's my location
in the 17th century
right
in korea right there lived three bears
mama pear papa bear baby bear
they lived in a log cabin
a wolf shows up
he blows the [ __ ] house down
combining two stories no this is a
korean one three if you count star wars
right we're at three ips right now right
then obi-wan
but that's the wolf's name
oh not not connected yeah yeah yeah
obi-wan the wolf cars obi wolf well what
what's going on
who's eating me and the beers are like
why'd you blow down our house [ __ ]
right we don't have a home now [ __ ]
he's like
the wolf and the wolf is like later
and he does this run yeah right
and the bears aren't as fast as the
[ __ ] wolf right yeah but they chase
and they're pissed off it took them by
the way a little backstory
they couldn't even find a contractor for
years to even build the [ __ ] thing
but it took five years to build this
thing right one blow wolf blows down the
[ __ ] whole lot they're chasing this
wolf right the wolf jumps off of cliff
he dies but we don't realize is that
wolf dude is the son
of a wolf mafia
well how do you know if we didn't
realize it that's exactly why because
it's a part two
oh it's a backstory right so it goes
back and forth bro now that same wolf
that jumped off the cliff is now a baby
because now we're starting right number
two
it's like a prequel right which is where
they actually get the term prequel
because of the wolf's fur is it's a
quilt they would do it and earlier was
the pre-quilt so anyway obi-wan the baby
ob
zero
no oh oh ob one is one well i gotcha you
know i'm not making this up this isn't
an actual korean folklore tale so i'm
just going by the book
so i don't know what the [ __ ] you're
doing
i don't know i think i'm forcing stuff
and i'm wrong go ahead no don't get in
your head you're doing great i'm not i'm
just sometimes you get in your head i
don't want you to get in your head i'm
okay okay good we're doing very well
right here
okay
so anyway when he was a kid what the
wolf
right
he had a wolf grandfather
and he goes oh be wall
right
40 years from now
you're gonna blow down these three bears
house
but you're not gonna know why
and then you're gonna die that's it
yeah man comedy's tough dude
it really is it's hard and we were in a
panda mate
i missed
i missed it on that one yeah yeah well
the problem isn't that you missed it
it's that it took you so long to realize
you didn't have it
well here's the problem you know i kept
you know what i kept going to see if i
could find it of course you requested
your instincts that was your first
mistake yeah i think
your dismount would have been that when
the wolf was like what's up guys or
whatever and you realize oh i don't have
it i gotta laugh let me pass it over to
a professional right and what i did was
i try to milk it
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know what you
were doing you you you were digging
because you were you just didn't know
what else to do and then you got lucky
and you found something and you threw it
away and you tell us an old jewish um
childhood fable
sure um
a long time ago in the uh
in the early aughts
of
1900 bc
2000 bc
there was this uh this evil pharaoh
okay
yeah
and i love by the way i love those
movies
the mummy yeah
no i love the mummy right i even like
the tom cruise one that's the mummy that
mama yeah yeah yeah yeah the brendan
fraser though they can't beat that i
also like any that one rock one what
rock was in the egypt one what was that
called oh the bad scorpion
i enjoyed that what was the one that you
were saying i said ten commandments yeah
but that's not you know the remaking
history of the world part two
yeah ike baron holds something to do
yeah agreement outs and dave stassen and
mel brooks yeah
you think you'll get in that tell me
this pharaoh what happened
locus frogs water parts you've all heard
that but what you haven't heard is
the other part
and that is with cayman and princess
esther do you guys know about heyman and
princess esther no i think so oh well
you've heard it
what do you tell us a story about
speaking fishing wait
let me
let's do a vault
everyone listening right now okay
what's a funnier fable mine wasn't a
funny fable my name was nothing funny
but it was like jews there's nothing
funny about the plight of the jews i
wasn't either yours was about obi-wan
the baby wolf no my mine was an analogy
on what how the japanese oppressed the
koreans that's why they came out explain
it
the japanese oppressed the koreans
explain the analogy
oh really but the wolf didn't steal
anything and actually the bears were the
ones that were chasing the wolf the wolf
the wolf represents north korea he came
to the [ __ ] part of the bears with
the crowd it seems like the architect
was the north korean who made a house
that could blow over from the wind now i
know why you're scared of the wind uh
and now i know why i love you i thought
you're going to call me a jewish [ __ ]
[Laughter]
this is a full circle it's a full circle
all circles are full otherwise they're
just silly use is there a filipino story
that you would like to fable any of you
well we have um a couple creatures that
might oh yeah you might that might pique
your interest i'll show you a picture
well the korean the jet the there's one
really hot one we have a thick balance
but the bat the bat's crazy um centaur
or what do you call minotaur centaur
which is the horse centaur is the one
with 100 legs